would you like me to take your clothes
off no thank you would you like me to
take my clothes off no thank
you Mom can you pick me up please I'm
having big feelings I can only afford
one daughter having a breakdown at a
time you
to well the thing about Josie is that
she's been experimenting with some ideas
well that sounds good no Dev no it's
not maybe she'll spot me across the room
and realize I'm the love of her life
don't think so sometimes and Mom forget
you're even there when you're standing
right next to us Billy
Johnson I'm going to marry that man have
you had your period yet oh you're
obsessed with my period it's like Dad it
will come back when it's
ready dev's a fresh start none of that
old baggage from the past where did he
take you today his dead wife's grave if
you don't lock that girl down you're
going to spend the rest of your life
waiting for death to come so you can
have another go in the next life you're
going to be an incredible mother we show
these women no fear not Deb not Josie
not Deb
said de
twice how point do you think the
maternal Instinct kicks in not sure I
still hoping I'm happen for Mom do I
look feminine you look great do I look
nice you look like the before picture in
a makeover show I guess we just have to
remember that most people aren't wor for
trauma like we are the trauma is all
we've got I know getting pregnant with
Josie was the worst mistake of my life
and not just because it was with Josie
should I go sorry I didn't realize you
were still here should
I
[Music]